Billy we've got to ask you we know you  keep in touch with Angelina  how is she holding up these days she  seems you know okay to me when I talk I  don't talk to her that often you know I  mean we're still very good friends but  you know she's got her world I've got  mine and you know once in a blue moon we  come together every now and then we talk  you know whatever but you know when  people are you know going through their  trials and tribulations I try to leave  them alone unless they want to talk to  me I know so I just kind of in other  words I figure it's none of my business  you know listen makes it my business is  none of my good into that phone rings  you'll be there for her imagine course  yeah well happy holidays love the  filming process  I want minecraft halo 5 guardians  Assassin's Creed chronicles treasure  that's great that's great I don't know I  have no idea what it is  you